or we're hearing about Labor reaction to
the local elections a short while ago
with our correspondent now Rishi sunak
has been out and about he's been talking
about the new government's plan to
increase funding and allow pharmacists
to do a lot more in the community
well one of my five priorities is kind
of waiting list and today's announcement
is getting on with that and it's about
Primary Care expanding access to
services that people can get from their
Pharmacy but also investing in general
practices in surgeries to end the 8 A.M
Scramble now when it comes to pharmacies
what we are doing is providing with
extra money so that people can go to
their pharmacy and get medicines for
common ailments like earaches sore
throats throat infections those kinds of
things that people will be able to
practically go to their pharmacies for
save them a visit or a call to the GP
because everyone loves their pharmacies
I know firsthand growing up what a
difference they make to people's lives
and it's right that we're backing them
to do more there are fewer pharmacies
pharmacies though aren't there yeah but
we're investing more in them 80 of the
country lives about 20 minutes walk from
a pharmacy and for many people there are
easier place to access than their
surgery that's why we're investing more
in them and allowing them to do more and
it's not just more medicines that people
will be able to get there they will get
more blood pressure checks or indeed
contraception as well so we're expanding
the range of services is that people can
get from their pharmacies that's good it
will ease pressure on the system mean
that people can get access to the health
care they need quicker and it backs all
our fantastic pharmacies as well with
extra funding
let's talk about GPS though let's be
clear about this because there's a
little bit of confusion this morning
you're not going to hit this target are
you a 6 000 GPS Manifesto pledge by
2024.
well so what we are doing on GP numbers
is straightforward so right now there
are almost 2 000 more doctors working in
general practice than there were in 2019
but also and I can I can speak with with
some knowledge of this it is the case
that not everyone needs to see a GP my
dad was a GP my mum was a pharmacist so
the other thing that we're doing is
investing in lots of other roles and
they're actually 25
000 more staff working in primary care
more generally if you talk to patients
at this practice that we're at they get
fantastic care from their nurse to treat
them for asthma another nurse for
diabetes or a physiotherapist all
different roles that we're investing
more in so that people can get the care
they need and allows GPS to focus on
what only they can do but we are
massively expanding the number of people
working in Primary Care in a practices
like this it's making a huge difference
to patients but just very specifically I
don't push you on this but it is not
going to be met that six thousand figure
can you just say that's correctly well
what we are going to be doing is
bringing forward shortly a plan for the
long-term plan for the NHS Workforce now
right now we have record numbers of
people in GP training that's a good
thing but we want to significantly
expand the number of specialist GPS
working so the long-term NHS Workforce
plan will set out our Ambitions and how
we're going to deliver that but they're
already record numbers we want to go
further and but as well as GPS it's
really important that we also consider
all the other roles in primary care and
I said we're investing in tens of
thousands more nurses physiotherapists
pharmacists as well to do more that
makes a big difference to patients these
are really practical things that as I
said ease the 8am scramble make it
easier to get the care that you need for
you and your family okay let's move on
to a few other subjects we can let's
talk about protesters and what happens
at the coronation on Saturday now
yesterday you supported police yesterday
the Met apologized to those protesters
in the end isn't the problem actually
operations police will make decisions on
a day-to-day basis it's the law that
you've brought in it's too wide don't
you think it needs to be looked at again
as even some of your MPS suggest it
should be looked at again the first
thing to say about the weekend is an
enormous thank you to everyone involved
in making sure that everything went off
so smoothly and was so successful a lot
of people worked incredibly hard
including the police to make sure that
that happened and I'm very grateful to
all of them as I think everyone will be
now with regard to protests you know
what I'd say is of course people have
the right to protest freely but
peacefully but it is also right that
people have the ability to go about
their day-to-day lives without facing
serious disruption and what the
government has done is give the police
the powers that they need to tackle
instances of serious disruption to
people's lives I think that's the right
thing to do and the police will make the
decisions on when they use those Powers
but was there nothing that happened that
made you feel uncomfortable you're right
we live in a democracy people have got
the right to protest these people didn't
have the right to protest they were
stopped from even protesting does not
make you feel a bit uncomfortable but we
also live in a society where the police
are rightly operationally independent of
government right they make the decisions
on the ground and the way that they see
fit that's the way that we've always
done it that's the right way to do it it
wouldn't be right for me to interfere
with their operational decisions but it
is right for the government to give the
police the powers they need to tackle
serious disruption because as we've seen
over the last weeks and months there are
lots of instances of people's day-to-day
lives being seriously disrupted by
protesters and people have rightly asked
well why isn't that being stopped so it
is right that the government gives the
police the powers to deal with those
things but again those are operational
decisions for the police on the ground
at the time okay just two final
questions one on the look election
results has it sunk in just how badly
you guys did last week I mean more than
a thousand seats is it just gonna be
enough to talk about your five key
targets repeatedly over and over again
obviously disappointing to lose
hard-working conservative counselors I
know that the country wants us to focus
on their priorities and I've set out
five very clear priorities to halve
inflation grow the economy reduce debt
cut waiting list and to stop the boats
and today that's what we're doing we're
getting on and delivering we're cutting
waiting lists in Primary Care by
expanding the range of services you can
get from your pharmacist by investing in
GP practices to end the 8am scramble
those are practical things that will
make a difference to people's lives
improve their lives for the better now
look I know that's not going to happen
overnight but what I can tell people is
we are working day and night to make
their lives better the priorities that I
set out I believe are the right ones
they're the country's priorities and
we'll keep working to deliver them okay
just very finally President Putin's been
speaking in Moscow this morning talking
about how the West is provoking
conflicts encouraging russophobia and
nationalism just your response to his
his speech today again attacking the
West at the time in which we may well
see increase and we have seen increase
in the tax in Ukraine there's only one
person who's responsible for the illegal
and unproval invasion of Ukraine and
that's President Putin and the crimes
that are being committed are appalling
the suffering that is being inflicted on
the Ukrainian people is appalling and
that's why it's right that we remain
steadfast in supporting the people of
Ukraine to stand up to that aggression
and that's what I and the United Kingdom
will continue to